testificar para que nadie olvide desde
hace varios meses dayton prepara su
intervención en una hoja de papel
escribe una serie de preguntas que hago
yo con todo esto y que haré después
quiere expresar todas las preguntas que
lleva dentro pero también contar aquella
noche de horror en el bataclán
moverse rodeado de cuerpos sin vida
pasar horas cubierto de sangre ajena
sólo quiero poder hablar de estos
pensamientos que me acompañan día y
noche desde hace casi seis años
ni gay tony los demás testigos podrán
dirigirse directamente a los acusados en
el tribunal pero su relato está por
supuesto destinado a ellos son jesús
me gustaría que admitirán que han sumido
a cientos y miles de vidas en la
desolación y la desesperación
y tengo la esperanza secreta de
devolverles la humanidad
adicional junto a gaitán
360 parte civiles declararon ante el
tribunal a pocos metros de los acusados